today on our show go into outer space
with Luke the Sun and valerian and the
city of a thousand plan I'm looking to
thousand hundred thousand thousand
thousand thousand not a million not for
overdoing it they could have got away
with a hundred planets yeah let their
French so it's up that was like a
[ __ ] peasant would have been okay
we're going to look at the final trailer
today on set man on Batman
that men on Batman welcome to fat man
about me I'm Kevin hi I'm Mark Barnard
okay man so the mullerian trailers have
been dropping like America's stock in
the world and and the third one or the
final one has hit about a week ago two
weeks ago movies in theaters July 21st
IIIi think the movie looks astounding I
don't know if anybody's talking about
this movie yet but I am like its it's
the one in the summer that's kind of my
my sleeper fade like most of the movies
I want to see this summer are well known
quantities this is not based on a Marvel
comic a DC comic but it is based on a
very famous french comic book that loved
the song the song has been dreaming of
making since he was supposed to be kid
and I'm a huge looper song fan yeah I
grew up like part of my formative
marketing thing everyone loves Luke the
song do they then I say everyone
everyone yes
took a bit we could see we didn't really
like that at all I know but it all
getting together it come together scene
that's because we are the professionals
it thank you we love Luke the sound let
them keep an amazing movie man we took a
lot of [ __ ] for that movie in France
because people like this is not French
when it first came out yeah it's very
American film and yet this dude stuck to
his style and redefined action
filmmaking so that American filmmaking
started aping what he did in movies like
La Femme Nikita and the professional aka
Leone Leone and then [ __ ] Fifth
Element development we move it out and
he says that Fifth Element he's like
I'll never be able to make valerian so
I'll make a version of valerian for me
and that was Fifth Element yeah there's
an element in a wonderful movie look
Bosson has like gone on to be a producer
of other people's work yes you've seen
the taken films the transformer the
transporter series a mechanic this is a
guy who he's not making his own stuff he
literally took I feel like 10 years off
to make other people's movies and you
know I interviewed him at the IMDB
boat last summer at comic-con and he
could have been more passionate about
this movie and man oh man I was before
anyone had seen a French film now the
footage is out there and it's stunning
all of it looks like a 70s album cover
like it looks like thor ragnarok dialed
up to 11 and painted with airbrushes
it's just beautiful and lush stars dane
dehaan and cara delevingne
the lady with the one eyebrow it was the
Enchantress consistent maybe maybe there
will be less floating wings of garbage
there's none of that
it's the enchantress and the Green
Goblin or the Hobgoblin or if you think
about it they know we're going to look
at this trail is the final trailer so
spinner up man it's called valerian in
the city of a thousand planets final
trailer that's what we're going to watch
ten theaters July 21st and here we ready
okay excuse me
trigger STX your Europa that's his
company all right that's pretty
beautiful that's nice and then you like
based on what grammar and graphic novel
you like never heard of it why is it
cranberry oh that Jesus look how [ __ ]
beautiful that is I'll work my whole
career I won't [ __ ] make a frame as
beautiful as that I can be it you ain't
kidding
look at this James Cameron must be like
[ __ ] hahaha god dammit I gotta lift my
game up well apparently he was working
on this for a long time in an avatar
came out and he had to totally refashion
was the class four without added what a
great notion city of a thousand plants
it kind of reminds me of that nowhere
look how we get that cut beautiful it is
look at this who staying into this [ __ ]
I mean I know he took it from a comic
book so the consul's people thought of
it but
you look clever and watch him when to
run and suit bamm-bamm
what a great sequence dude the runners
who you just [ __ ] run through any
wall it's genius that's kind of amazing
did all of that it's [ __ ] beautiful
Lucy that's another one he did I made a
[ __ ] denim oh and he's underwater now
let me throw bot read a bald chick I'm
like go see this in IMAX
come on dude like this is crazy it looks
like a comic book come to life it makes
me want to read this comic book even
though it's in French Clive Owens back
dude I mean there's a world in which I
don't even need this to make sense yeah
just I just kind of want to look at it
just be beautiful
it's be as beautiful as it is over and
over again God isn't that just like yeah
I mean I would like it to make sense I
was like things make sense but if it's
just gonna be like a feast for the
senses that's not the worst thing in the
world here's something I'd like to point
out this book that's based on is old mmm
cuz luck poisson loved it when he was a
kid Luca Bassam he loved it when he was
a 13 year old boys or 12 or 13 when
dreaming about this movie so the story
is about valerian and Laura lein his
partner mm-hmm pretty progressive for a
book that's that old yeah you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah pretty woke for a
[ __ ] 40 30 40 year-old comic book I
mean it's also French and three do you
think it's pre Star Wars should we look
it up well we could look it up we can do
the research fill the air would you it
would not surprise me if it's pre Star
Wars because I mean Barbarella was pre
Star Wars like the French the French
comic scene has a sort of long history
at granted a lot of it is kind of sex
based or eroticism based finding lately
but that's all for sex oh okay give me
like a meal of Milo Manara me little
mini yeah like all that stuff and it's a
long history and some of that stuff is
beautiful beyond the titillation factor
so it doesn't surprise me that the we're
going to have a young man and a young
woman on a space adventure together but
only [ __ ] dude what it created
I fear Christian and jean-claude
messieurs valerian and Laura lein also
known as valerian spatio-temporal agent
or just valerian is a French science
fiction comic series created by writer
Pierre Christian and artist Jean Claude
Messner's is first published in pilot or
pilot a magazine billete on like I never
took French in get ready for it in 1967
Wow
so you look at that trailer and you're
like oh that looks like a lot of movies
I've seen guess what that's what I stole
a pub it's good the valerian one first
apparently man the final installment was
published in 2010 all the valerian
stories have been collected in graphic
novel album format comprising some 21
volumes plus a short story collection
and an encyclopedia you can see dive on
this [ __ ] man so it's like here's some
of the titles valerian and bad dreams
city of shifting waters Empire of a
thousand planets the best video mm last
world without stars birds of the master
ambassador of the shadows on the false
Earth's goddess I'm crazy Adel I know
it's pretty damn feeling and it's like
we're always sitting here talking about
Batman spider-man French they got their
own heroes man you could make your spot
oh man we have balerion spider-man is a
geek that man is the death of
intellectualism
valerian is the picture this it looks
fantastic
like hats off to this dude once again
and hats off to anybody who's like I had
a dream and you know I couldn't let it
go because I've done a lot of cool [ __ ]
but you know push the pedal of the metal
make that dream Avenue he did yeah I
mean is there's also a little hint of
like almost Fantastic Voyage like that
that's 60 super [ __ ] acid trippy or
science filling that with a little
either right oh well oh yeah into the
human body like that that weird like
Barbarella that we're just it's all like
high pop art house like pulp looks
expensive let's just leave it at that he
spent all the money my god they have all
the money they stole
but all in fact on this movie so we
should go out here when it happens we
have soon deliveries to make a velarium
where be absolutely so yeah nice where
you spent - tell me Canada a little bit
it's kind of France
it's American France
there it is valerian comes out in July
I'm buying a ticket
I took it now man well go trip yeah
let's all go we'll bring you guys with
us in the theater we'll live stream it
right before coming to make all the
money anyway more at the box office or
it'll just be a night in the theater
totally free it's nothing last night I
saw the Fifth Element and then to hear
Scott Mosier and Seattle grant it was
like a noon show on Friday but it opened
but still it was a weird experience but
then again a lot of people have seen
sauce can you goes completely they know
what I'm talking about
I'll make this thing it'll be [ __ ]
empty really so nighttime you know what
it feels like it can occupy the same
space that gamal del Toro's robots
versus monsters a little bit of rim rim
job it feels like this could do the rim
job
it feels like this is either rim job or
Jupiter ascending oh don't say that
this looks way more I mean yeah but we
saw the trailers for Jupiter setting
like the [ __ ] wachowski and we're in
space and huh awesome oh that guy's got
a [ __ ] in the mouths of everything that
could be good you know there's got to
bring us down to earth I was up in the
[ __ ] city of a thousand planet my
head was up there and you brought me
right back down I see a mouth it'll put
[ __ ] in it Larry and Laura lein your new
missions your business seems to be good
Wow me you were going yeah gorgeous
absolutely there it is Batman I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark and tune in
next episode we'll watch something else
you watch us watch another [ __ ] yeah
same bat-time same bat-channel podcast
calm or you to become slash Kendall
Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]